question 27 he won't like aa business
model what does that mean we talked
about this it just means making money
okay
now question 27 a it says compare and
contrast three distinct business models
okay three different ways of making
money using multimedia systems that's
what it says in the end okay so let me
give you one two three four five six six
okay I've got six different ways that I
thought of and start up over that with
previous questions right so number one
traditional payment this is the easy one
okay
users get charged on a per item basis
for what they want okay you like this
song you pay a dollar 69 for it okay
well you want to watch this video for 24
hours where you can hire it both of
those ways are just the traditional
payment way just like you go to the shop
pay something from another okay
down the line number 2 subscription
subscription that's when you pay money
for you know a regular charge
irrespective of how much you've used and
that way you get access to a broad range
of you know content so that's the way
Netflix works basically higher fees you
might get greater features like much
behind-the-scenes footage or interviews
that kind of thing or you might get a
broader set of materials like more
channels that's the way I think Foxtel
works the more you pay the more channels
would get access to you so one
traditional payment to subscription 3
advertising so instead of charging the
users you're in charge of anything they
get to watch for free who are you
charging if you're a content creator who
are you charging good right some
companies they're like well this company
this this TV show is popular I want to
put my product in front of its viewers
eyes so you're charging those companies
for screen time
okay so advertising you can say inline
ads or overlay ads or product placements
or banner space they're all different
ways of advertising okay now before this
is a core no one mentioned it though I
don't think much merchandise here okay
now a lot of you - creatives make the
bulk of their money this way because
advertising Zach
we only like cents at a time line woohoo
I made seven cents of this video okay
merchandise eating things like t-shirts
and cups and posters and signed
paraphernalia those kinds of things
right so users aren't charged for the
content they're charged for peripheral
items that relate to the content kept
you can make some real money that way
number five one I've already mentioned
which is crowdfunding so uses pledged
funds before the production begins okay
and then you know you if you're a back
are you get perks or rewards for backing
the project okay
sixth one last one pay walls
pay walls what's a pay wall you get to
access a little bit of something like
say the first paragraph run of an
article but then if you want to read the
whole thing gonna pay a little bit so
similar to traditional payment but not
quiet it's a little bit like yeah you
can have the first bite of that
cheeseburger for free pay me two dollars
if you want the rest of it okay so it's
not quite traditional payment paywalls
it's a very common thing online okay so
you had to what does compare and
contrast mean by the way you can't just
say what those businesses are you have
to provide some points of comparison
some things which are similar like do
users get charged for the content or not
is it free to them do they get charged
per item or is it a regular charge who's
the actual source of revenue is that the
user or is it some company who wants to
advertise is there a requirement for
intermediary parties right like say
iTunes that takes thing Apple takes
their cut right is it continuous or
educational those are the kinds of
things I was looking for you to say yes
they're similar or yes nor they're
different
that's a compare and contrast means
right